a 17 year old now has her very own horse  thanks to the make-a-wish foundation  bailey king was diagnosed with a heart  condition when she was just three years  old since then she's had several  surgeries and takes daily medication to  treat her illness while bailey has grown  up around horses she's never had one to  call her own today that all changed  i've loved it ever since i watched the  you know the movie spirit and stuff and  i was like oh i kind of always you know  want a horse of my own so i was like oh  when i  got mentioned the wish and stuff i was  like maybe i could try and just you know  wish for something that i've wanted  since i was you know little  i love it well make-a-wish says they  believe the horse will bring bailey the  comfort and support she needs to  continue with her medical journey